when it comes to June all the big news
happens at e3 so we come through the
headlines to bring you the biggest games
that surprised us at the show hit that
subscribe button and you'll get every
news video delivered right to you and
remember that you can catch more ìiî
coverage of all of these games on
gamespot.com there were a handful of
leaks for Mario Plus Rabbids Kingdom
battle but what's surprising is that
when the game was finally revealed
during Ubisoft's press conference it
looks great
like a cartoony take on XCOM will be
learning even more as we near the games
Nintendo's switch exclusive launch at
the end of August another game that
leaked and another one that Wow's us
when it was finally revealed Assassin's
Creed origins is looking to redefine the
series we've got a new protagonist and
egyption setting and revamped combat
that takes cues from the souls series
and yes I'm totally expecting some
supernatural mummy DLC as the name
implies this is a prequel to the modern
cult classic adventure game before the
storm focuses on Chloe
the main supporting character from the
first game telling the story of her days
at the school before the first game
kicked off this new chapter will be told
across just three episodes but a proper
sequel is also in development
[Music]
anthem looks a bit like destiny with a
pinch of mass effect but Bioware is
aiming for more with its new IP studio
manager Aaron Flynn says the game is
much more like Star Wars with lots of
crazy unexplained sci-fi action we'll
definitely be seeing more of anthem in
its many mech suits before its 2018
launch window Nintendo's e3 spotlight
hit us with a double dose of Metroid
news prime for is happening on switch
but that's about all we know we saw a
lot more of Samus Returns on 3ds a
reimagining of Metroid 2 which
originally released on the Gameboy new
abilities better aiming and more combat
options make this one to watch when it
launches on September 15 for those who'd
rather shoot Nazis than aliens
there's Wolfenstein 2 the new Colossus
imagines a world where the Third Reich
one and took America by force
BJ blaskowitz is back to fight for his
country from within his country it's
launching at the end of October just in
time for everyone to make bad Halloween
costume choices I haven't mentioned any
fighting games yet so let's change that
Dragonball Fighter Z is from the team
behind guilty gear in blazblue which
means this will probably be the best
playing and looking Dragon Ball fighting
game ever it's not launching until next
year so for now let's all admire the 2.5
D graphics and classic characters
this III was largely devoid of remakes
but one game that's getting a fresh coat
of paint is Shadow of the Colossus yes
there was already a remaster that
released alongside eco for the ps3 but
imagine taking down the colossi now with
all the 60 frames and 4k and HDR support
the ps4 pro can pull off will see just
what it can do sometime in 2018 oh did
you think the Metro series was done
Metro Exodus continues after the events
of last light in stars Artyom and Anna
now a married couple the one year story
starts in nuclear winter and the journey
will take you all across the continent
through rivers and over mountains you'll
be able to hop on the train sometime
next year
and finally it's number one because most
of you probably thought it would never
actually happen but Beyond Good and Evil
2 was indeed the closer at Ubisoft
conference director Michelle on sale
later showed off a tech demo which
featured one of the custom space monkey
protagonists a bunch of ships and a huge
city platforms and release dates are
totally up in the air with this one no
pun intended and those are the games
that surprised us this month which ones
are you looking forward to playing sound
off in the comments and remember you can
always grab our game spot now app on iOS
and Android for all the most popular
stories